[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay, [FOREIGN], Malala.
>> [FOREIGN] Thank you.
>> Clearly, the GSP is very
excited to have you here today.
Before we start, I want to say
a personal thank you, Malala.
As a fellow Pakistani, a brother to two
sisters, a son to a mother back in Karachi
is I'm humbled and filled with gratitude
to share the stage with you today.
>> Thank you so much and
I'm also honored to be here.
Thank you so much to everyone for
your presence and I'm so
excited to have this conversation.
>> Great, there are a lot of important
topics we have to cover today.
We don't have too much time.
I want to start with one,
which is very important to the both of us.
>> Yes.
>> And that's Cricket.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Have you been
following the World Cup in the last week?
>> Yes, I always follow Cricket and
I even would watch any league,
any match that is to do with Cricket and
I watched as much as well
that are five days long, but
T20 is the shortest in
the international ones and
Pakistan is doing really well this time.
It started with India,
then you beat them, then New Zealand.
Again, we won.
And today, it was Afghanistan,
we w on again.
I think in the last two overs,
a lot of people had given up and
they thought Pakistan was going to lose,
but I had full faith.
A Pakistan was going to win today and
my intuition is never wrong.
>> Wow, there you go.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Great, so
let's perhaps start with Pakistan.
Before you were even ten years old back
in Swat, you were allowed advocate in
your community for close education and
drills being in school.
That's not I would say typical of
a ten-year old girl in Pakistan.
What made you do that at that early age?
>> I think people often time
hear about my story and
they are surprised that
I was speaking out for
my right to education at age 10,
11 and it is an unusual story but.
Also, this was the case, because what I
was experiencing was unusual for girls.
And that was because at that time,
the Pakistani Taliban had
entered Swat Valley in 2007.
They started spreading this ideology
of establishing the so-called
Islamic state and they wanted to bring
in their own so-called Sharia system and
they wanted to like Pakistan
was already an Islamic country.
So how do you make another Islamic
country inside in an Islamic country?
But then along with that, they also
had this narrative against women and
they carry a very patriarchal mindset.
As soon as they entered,
they banned women from going to markets.
They banned women from having any
profession from going to work.
They will not allow them to go
outside their houses without wearing
a full shuttlecock burqa and
you had to have a custodian with you,
it could even be your little brother.
And I remember my mom or me or any woman
like going outside to see a doctor or
somebody and they would have these
little boys with them and I would always
question, how's this little boy going
to protect me, right, they can't.
Instead, I'm protecting them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But at that time,
they also announced a ban on girls
education and I could not go to school.
My friends could not go to school.
So I had no choice, but to speak out for
my right to go to school.
>> And I want to touch on the role
your father played, the Godin.
You've spoken about him previously.
How much of an influence was he in
that upbringing at that early age,
especially when it comes to education?
>> I'm really proud of my dad.
He is a proud feminist and
he saw that his own five
sisters could not get their education, and
they did not have access
to a future that he had.
And he knew that his life was different,
because he was a boy nothing else.
Gender played a role in deciding
the destinies of of the siblings and
he was really passionate about
bringing equality into society.
So he decided that when
he has his own children,
he would ensure that they're not
discriminated based on their gender.
And he has always loved me and
he has been a proud that
he has encouraged me to believe in myself,
and
I always tell people that my
story is not an exception story.
It could have been the story of
any girl if their fathers and
their brothers had allowed
them to speak out.
Many were stopped by their family members.
Many were stopped by men in the society.
What's different in my story is
that my father did not stop me.
And that's what he says when you ask him,
what did you do for your daughter?
He says that don't ask me what I did, but
asked me what I did not do and
I did not clip her wings.
So it's a message to women and girls all
around the world that they don't need
any sort of superpower or anything
special to go ahead in their life.
There are so many barriers in front of
them that makes it more difficult for
them to go ahead.
So we need to fight against those
barriers, the glass ceiling,
the iron bars in their way and
men have a role to play in that.
So for me,
my dad has always been supportive and
I have always been this sort
of I like giving advice.
So I'm always there telling my dad how
things should be and what we should do.
When you're like a kid and
that's your thing, and that's how
you talk to your family members.
So I have carried it on since then,
but he always listens.
He's a great dad.
>> Great and just on your father, I read
somewhere that he also named you, Malala.
It's a beautiful name.
You tell us more about
the story behind your name.
>> So Malala means grief-stricken,
basically in Pashto,
but the name has more
historical meaning as well.
And it was a name of this Afghan, heron.
Malalai of my one and
she came from this area in Afghanistan.
And her story goes like this that there
was the second Anglo Afghan War and
the Afghan soldiers were
losing that battle, and
they were leaving the battlefield.
When this young woman went to the
mountaintop and she raised her voice and
told the soldiers that if you do
not die on this battlefield today,
you will live your life in shame forever.
And her voice was so powerful that
all the soldiers returned and
they fought that war, and they won.
I think it has more
meaning in our culture and
she's probably the only
Pashtoon hero that we have,
and who is known by her own name.
And so
my father was just really proud of her and
he Wanted to name me after somebody
who was known by her own name.
>> Right, now I think that's beautiful
just based off the life you've lived so
far, how it Mirrors Malala and
I know that story.
So let's perhaps just move on,
fast forward a few years.
You're 17 years old now.
This is late 2012, early 2013,
after the Taliban attack.
You're recovering,
the months are rolling by,
you're in a different country,
you're in the UK.
Take us back to that time of helplessness,
of despair,
you've gone through such a lot.
How did you think about what you
wanted to do next in your life?
And kind of just put us in that position
and how did you think about that?
>> So when I was in the hospital,
I had no idea that I was receiving so
much support from around the world.
I was not seeing any television,
any mobile phone,
and I was going under all
the health care and treatment.
And then one day this staff member
at the hospital brought this
basket of cards and letters.
And I was opening those cards and
reading messages from people
from all over the world.
A letter from a five
year old girl to a letter
from an eight year old person in the US or
in Japan.
And I was completely amazed and surprised
that people had heard my story and
they were sending their prayers and
they were sending me even gifts.
From shampoo to scarves to shoes to
anything you could possibly think of.
And I was completely amazed,
and then the staff member told
me that this is just one box,
there are so many boxes there with us.
You have received thousands and
thousands of cards from people
from all over the world.
And that's when I realized that I
can speak out for girls globally.
The Taliban tried to silence me,
but they made a huge mistake.
Because I am in a position where I can not
only speak about my right to education and
for girls in Swat Valley, but
I can speak out for girls globally.
And since then it has been my mission to
ensure that all 130 million girls who
are out of school can
have access to education.
>> Thats good.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So that's the mission,
the 130, free, safe, quality education for
girls around the world.
How did you come up with the idea
of a fund or a foundation?
Who who helped you,
who guided you at that early age?
Walk us through that process of why
the fund was the best vehicle to
achieve that mission
>> So I'll be honest,
when I started this foundation, I wasn't
really sure how these things worked.
I was, I think 16, years old.
I was also studying,
I was a bit behind in my studies because I
had missed a few years
because of my treatment.
So I had to do my homework and
I had to be in school and
then I had to do these events because
I was invited to different places.
And then I started a foundation
as well called Malala Fund.
And initially when I was asked,
what do I want focus on?
And I said, on girls education,
I want all girls to be in school.
That's what I want to work for.
But then they said no, no,
you have to be a bit more specific.
Do you want to work in this country or
that country and
do you want to build schools or
do you want, so many questions?
I was like no, I want to do everything.
I want all girls to be in school,
I can't pick.
This has been the mission for
us since then, that we fight for
all girls who are out of school.
And we currently work in more than
eight countries including Pakistan,
Nigeria, Brazil, India,
Afghanistan, Lebanon.
And our mission is to ensure that
we work with local activists,
and we support the local led
projects that address the issues and
the barriers that girls face
in their pride to education.
So it could be from training female
teachers, to changing legislations,
to addressing social norms and
engaging the local communities.
And the work has been remarkable
when you work with local activists,
because they identify the problem but they
also identify solutions to those problems.
>> That's great,
you mentioned earlier studying,
and you graduated from Oxford
last year in the summer.
But you've been an activist
well before that,
before Oxford, back in Swat and
since the attacks as well.
What did you get from
that classroom education?
I believe you were at PPE at Oxford.
How did the classroom education over those
three years change your view on how to
approach this problem and
just your approach and advocacy and
activism compared to what you knew before?
>> I'll be honest.
When I was studying at
university at Oxford,
education was still important to me,
but it was not a priority.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because they tell you that you learn
a lot from your textbooks and
from your lectures but
you also learn a lot from meeting
people and socializing with people.
And I will be honest I met
incredible people there,
I made amazing friends and
I'm friends with them now forever.
And I also got
the opportunity to engage and
interact with incredible professors and
these amazing
intellectual people whose books
I'll be reading for my essays.
So it's just great to
have that opportunity.
And then Oxford is just so beautiful.
So you spent a lot of time in
the beautiful gardens and libraries there.
And you spend amazing
time with your friends.
And then you go through essay crisis,
and then you're awake the whole night
just to finish your essay
that you left the last day.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I mean, it's your fault and
every week you are just depressed.
Why did you do this to yourself again?
But it happens and then you don't regret
having all those incredible experiences.
So you're like fair enough and
then you submit your essay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And go back to sleep at 8am in
the morning.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm sure there are many people here who
can relate to that experience.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You shouldn't be so hard on yourself.
I want to go back to the fund's mission,
130 million
girls who you want to get back
into school K through 12.
This last few months and
the last year has been difficult for
that mission,
on a number of different reasons.
Perhaps let's just go back
to August of this year,
the Taliban recapture Afghanistan.
How did you receive that news?
How did it sit with you?
What was your initial reaction
having already lived through
that nine years previously?
>> No one expected the Taliban to
take over Afghanistan, no one.
And I remember just two weeks
before the Taliban took over Kabul,
I had a call with all the activists
that we were supporting in Afghanistan,
our education champions there.
And some of them still had hope that
Afghanistan can never fall into the hands
of the Taliban.
And so, just like everyone else,
the whole world was shocked.
I was shocked as well,
to see that the Taliban were now
in the whole country, and
they were ruling over people.
And I think, it's again,
a gloomy time for women and girls there.
And we already see the impact of that.
Women have lost opportunity to
walk freely to their job places,
many of them have not
returned to their workplace.
And girls at this time, are not sure
if they can go back to schools or not.
The Taliban announced,
I think 43 days ago,
that boys can return to schools, but
they did not give any clear statement on
whether girls can return
to their schools or not.
So, we started then a petition
together with Afghan activist and
it's on avast.org and
we are asking the Taliban to
immediately let girls be in schools.
We're also asking G20 leaders
in the Muslim countries to
take a bold stand for this.
They must protect the rights of girls and
they must protect the right
to education for girls.
Afghanistan right now is the only country
in the world where girls are not allowed
to be in school.
>> And just on that issue, Malala,
sometimes it's difficult for
us to visualize the 130 million
girls who are not in school.
Where you're at Stanford in California,
dare I say much very much a bubble
compared to the issues that were
all seen on the frontlines.
Can you help us understand why is this
not just a women's or a girls' issue,
but an issue for everyone?
And this is not something that countries
in another part of the world need to
worry about.
But this is truly a global issue for
everyone around the world.
>> I think firstly, we need to remember
that the Taliban government in
Afghanistan right now,
it's a forceful government.
It's not by the choice of
the people of Afghanistan.
They had no say in this.
The Taliban have captured
those cities by force,
even though they claim that
they have not fired their guns.
But they still were holding
guns on their shoulders and
they still had the cuffs on their
shoulders, so they are using power, they
are using their military power to suppress
people, to force people to accept them.
But also they're denying people
their basic human rights and
they're not very clear about that.
They are giving very vague statements on
protecting the human rights of people.
So I think this is the time that all
the world leaders who speak about
protecting humanity and who speak
about standing up for human rights,
that they stand up for
the rights of the people of Afghanistan.
And it's really important for
them to protect the rights of women and
girls, to protect the rights of
minorities, especially but also ensure
that all the humanitarian assistance and
aid is provided to people there.
We know that the presence of the Taliban
has impact in the lives of people but
there's also other issues like COVID and
severe drought as well.
So those issues cannot be denied either,
it's going to a stage of famine as well.
And these are issues
that must be considered.
So, this is what our advocacy and
our activism is asking for
leaders to act soon.
>> You mentioned advocacy activism.
Typically that's work
done by the government,
by the nonprofit sector,
by foundations and so on.
A lot of us here will graduate from the
GSB and enter the business community and
the private sector potentially.
What is the role of businesses in
the private sector in partnering in
various ways in solving this problem?
>> I think this is a question and
this is a challenge, and
I don't have answers to
all of these questions.
But I will say that everybody has a role
to play in ensuring support to those
who do not have a voice right now, who
do not have the support that they need.
A lot of people right now
in Afghanistan need safety.
And there have been many organizations,
including businesses who have helped
in the evacuation of so many people.
So I think the top priority is to
ensure that the people in Afghanistan,
especially the activists who
are under threat from the Taliban,
that they receive safety and protection.
And we did that for our activists in
Afghanistan and for other families.
And a lot of other organizations and
government officials have done that for
many families there.
So that is essential.
But along with that,
we also need to explore other ways in
which we can use our expertise and
resources to make education more
accessible for children in Afghanistan.
And I think this is something
where business community can help.
How can we use the technology that we
have to ensure that education is given
to girls in Afghanistan in other
ways rather than formal schooling.
And along with that,
I think still humanitarian assistance and
support is needed.
And businesses have the opportunity
to support the work that
is happening there for
the safety and protection of people,
for ensuring that they're
given their basic needs.
So again there are so
many ways in which people can help but
it also requires collective
effort to think through this and
also engage the people of
Afghanistan in these conversations.
>> You mentioned technology.
I believe you recently had a partnership
announced with Apple based in
Silicon Valley,
tell us more about what's the vision
behind that partnership with Apple?
>> So, with Apple, Malala Fund has been
working over the past many years and
Apple has supported our projects.
So it was also covering the work
that we are doing in Afghanistan and
then other countries like Nigeria,
India, Pakistan and
we run this activist program which is
called Malala Fund Education Activist.
And we have I think more than 50 activist
in all of those countries right now and
they are working on addressing
the problems that girl face in their local
communities.
For instance, when COVID started,
our activist in Nigeria,
they conducted a research
straight away and
they were looking at the impact
of COVID-19 on girls education.
And they realized that girls missed out on
their education because they don't have
access to digital tools.
They are also more likely to be
forced into marriages when they
are stuck in their houses, and
they also could be supporting
their families financially or
in the household chores.
And so then they, our activists,
they started doing lessons through radios.
So they would ensure that even if
the girls cannot attend their schools
because of COVID, they're still
learning their lessons through radio.
And that is the best form of
technology in those areas,
other technological devices and
tools may not work.
And so, that is just one example of how
they are just ensuring that children do
not miss out on education and
they keep on learning.
So Apple,
they are one of our biggest supporters and
it's great to work with them.
>> So that's an example of your
time commitments, your priorities,
partnering with Apple.
And you're obviously, you travel around
the world, do a bunch of speeches,
you're meeting students, you're also
at the grassroots level visiting
refugee camps, and schools and so on.
As you think about your personal time,
Where do you feel your own time is
best used in that fight against getting
the 130 million girls back into school?
What's most important for your time?
>> I think I'm always there
when my voice is needed, and
I was very fortunate that I got
the opportunity to visit countries and
to join girls who needed
their voices to be heard.
I have been to Nigeria, Iraq, Lebanon,
Jordan and I have met incredible
girls who are fighting for
their right to safety and education.
And many of these girls
have faced displacement and
they have seen wars and
conflicts in their hometown.
And they are living in refugee camps or
informal settlements,
but they have not given
up on their dreams.
Often time, I'm expected to inspire
them but it's the other way around,
they inspire me and
everyone else who are joining us.
And I remember there was one girl I met,
her name was Nigella in Iraq, and
she was girl and her family were
decided that she should get married.
She was only 14 years old and
she was in her wedding dress.
And on that day, she decided that she
does not want to be forced into marriage,
she does not want to miss
out on her education.
So she took off her high heels and
she ran away to protect herself from that.
And then later on when she came back,
she tried to convince her father and
her family to allow her to be in school
and she started going back to school.
But then when ISIS came into her hometown,
they had to evacuate, again,
and now when I met her,
she was in this informal settlement.
But she was still passionate about
learning and getting her education, and
I saw that she was carrying
a dictionary with herself.
And I asked her, I said,
why do you carry a dictionary with you?
She said,
I want to learn a few words every day.
So this is the passion that girls
carry for education and learning.
And despite all the difficulties
that they face from walking for
long distances and not having
all the resources like books and
teachers, they still are committed
to receiving their education.
Nigella was incredible,
then she also came to the US and
she spoke at the UN platform,
and she shared her story.
So my goal is to meet these girls,
but also uplift their voices.
So like leaders, listen to them rather
than me, and this is my goal in
every meeting that I go to is that
the activists and girls are with me.
And I introduced myself but
I'm like, let's listen to Nigella.
Let's listen to these activists and
they have something to say to you.
You have been ignoring their voices,
so hear from them and
they will tell you what the issues
are in this country for girls and women.
>> That's beautiful, just hearing the
stories themselves is a lot more powerful
than advocates and so on and so forth.
Previously, you've also mentioned
potentially interest in politics.
Is that still on the roadmap?
Now that you're done with Oxford,
what's next?
>> No, not yet.
No interest in politics.
I think when I said that I
wanted to be the prime minister
of Pakistan at that time,
I was 12 or 13 years old.
And I was really disappointed with
the role of our political leaders,
because what was happening in
SWAT was just taking so long.
And for me it was just absurd that
no one would take any action.
And as days went by, and I thought girls
in SWAT Valley cannot go to school,
there is a conflict,
our schools are bombed.
We hear firing every night, we are having
sleepless nights, and we are under threat.
And no one does anything, and
it happens for two years.
So at that time, I said, okay, fine I
asked you guys you didn't do anything so
I'll I'll one day become the prime
minister and I'll fix it.
But then I was really fortunate that I
have so much experience and I have met so
many amazing and incredible people and I
have been able to visit so many projects.
I know that the world is
a bit more complex, but
you can bring change in many ways.
You don't have to be a politician
to be a change maker.
You can bring change in any role that
you take in your society from becoming
a doctor, engineer, business person, to
a politician or to human rights activists.
All of these opportunities gives us
some ways in which we can contribute to
the change that we want
to see in the world.
So I hope to continue my activism and
ensure that we see that day when
all girls can go to school.
>> And
on the topic of change in many ways,
there's this wave of young
activists in the last few years.
And it's very refreshing to see
the younger generation standing up and
having their voices heard.
Different activists, advocates
have different styles in how they
engage with the issues that
they're tackling the community.
How would you describe your style?
Where does that come from?
What brings that out in you?
>> I think for me, there are a few
rules that I follow in my advocacy.
One is that my voice and
my words should reflect me and
who I am and what my values are.
And then along with that,
it's also important for
me, that whatever I say is the truth.
So as long as you are speaking the truth,
and as long as you are yourself,
then that should be your form of advocacy.
But I also think that we are all
in different positions and
in different places.
And some of us want to
work from the inside,
some of us want to work from the outside.
And I think, we all have a role to play,
and we are all helping each other.
So I do not underestimate or undermine the
activism that other people are taking in
different forms,
I think it's incredibly powerful.
And and all the activists should just
realize that they're all on the same side.
They're all on the same side and
they must support each other because
that helps them in achieving their goal.
They have a lot more in common, and they
must not lose focus on the issues that
they want to address and
the change that they want to bring.
So in the education field or in other
fields when there is activism happening,
I appreciate the role of
every person in there.
>> And speaking about different types
of activism and different causes and so
on, The Malala Fund in your vision is for
girls education.
But there are so many other issues and
justices reported in the media,
some not even mentioned in the media
happening all around the world.
Given your voice, your platform Olala,
how do you think about when
to speak up and when not to?
>> There are some issues
that have impacted me,
and that have been part of my story.
And I think I should be speaking
out about those issues.
And that issue includes girls education,
I speak out for girls right to
education all over the world.
But then I also speak out about what is
happening like in parts of Pakistan and
Afghanistan.
Because we had also been
part of that long decades,
long terrorism,
that the people have faced there.
Whether it's the Pakistani Taliban,
or Afghan Taliban,
they have all They all
carry the same ideology and
the same acts and
we all have been their victims.
So I speak out about that as well.
And I speak out about the issues
that impact girls education, but
there are other issues as well in which
it connects to girls education and
my mission but sometimes like I'm not
the best person to speak out for that.
There are so many other people
who have expertise in that, and
I ensure that the platform is there,
and I support them.
So, there are many things which
I do not speak out about,
because I just want to ensure that
my voice is for girls education and
that is understood that this is my mission
and this is what I will use my voice for.
>> Yep.
You're traveling around the world.
You're used to be a student as well.
You're juggling a lot of different things.
We see you on TV and in the news very
often, like how do you think about
work life balance and just personal
health, [LAUGH] his working life?
Is there even a blur or
is there a balance there?
>> I would say it was very
difficult when I was in school,
because, I used to have
homework like every day and
I had to attend my classes
from 8AM till 4PM in the UK.
So it was quite challenging and
I remember one time I had a flight
to Norway to attend some event.
And I think it was like over
the weekend or something but
I was arriving the next
morning in the morning time.
So I was like,
I can't miss my school days, so
I took my school uniform with me [LAUGH].
And then on the way back, I went straight
to my school, change into my uniform and
then I was like, I can't go home.
I would miss my classes.
So, it was challenging.
But it was important for
me that I focus on my education.
But also I give time to my activism for
the education of all girls
all around the world.
But I had to focus on my education
because if you seek out for education and
don't focus on yours,
>> [LAUGH].
>> You are missing the point.
>> Great, are there any other day
to day activities mindfulness,
is there anything you do on a daily
basis that kind of helps you stay
committed to that work life
balance you mentioned?
>> I really like, staying in touch
with my friends and talking to them.
I like spending time with people
Could be like our family friends and
my own school friends or university
friends, and I like playing games
as well as at one point it was among us,
if anyone had played it.
>> [LAUGH].
I think we are all like
done with that right.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We have moved on.
After that, I like playing cricket
with my brothers and badminton.
And I watch TV shows as well.
I have seen squid game so,
>> [LAUGH].
>> The first episode literally
shocked me and I was like,
>> [LAUGH].
>> What is happening but then after
that I think you get used to it so,
>> [LAUGH].
>> That was good and
then in the middle I had to like stop I
was like okay I need to
switch to something else so
I went to Ted last so and
he made me like [LAUGH] laugh and
just realize life is more positive and
easy and yeah.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I want to move on to there's a on to
just perhaps, criticisms that you face.
And it's shocking to me personally,
but given the work you're doing,
the work you've done and what you've been
through, there is no shortage of pushback.
Where does that come from?
Where is it bad out from that criticism?
>> I think firstly depends
what the criticism is and
if we clarify and explain that.
But if somebody says that,
I should do this and
not that and I haven't done enough for
this or that and
sometimes I have to remind people,
I am not a government.
I don't have trillions of dollars and
I don't have a central bank.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And, I am not that person but my goal
is to use my voice and the resources
I have to convince governments
to invest in education in women.
And ensure that
the resources are allocated
into the right areas that
benefits our society,
that empowers women and girls.
But my focus is always that I am
working for girls around the world and
the right to education.
So I feel like I'm only
answerable to myself, and
the people I have made commitment to
ensure that we make a better world.
Other than that,
people can say anything right.
And I think also in on social media,
you see comments and things like that.
And you would see like 20 positive
ones and just one negative one and
then all our focus is on
the negative one right.
We dismiss all the positive ones.
But I think it's important to remember
that sometimes the social media
world does not actually represent
the real world that we live in.
And I will say that, so
far I have not seen anyone in person
who has been hateful to me,
who has said anything negative.
They have always been supportive and
even if they have been critical,
they have done it in a very polite way.
So I don't worry too much about that.
>> That's great, specifically,
maybe lasering in on Pakistan,
you visited since the attack.
The pandemic has obviously
made that more difficult.
What is your long-term kind
of ambition with Pakistan and
what you want to see there, and
the role you want to play there?
I hope I can go to Pakistan more often,
and I was planning to go already but
then pandemic made things
a bit more difficult.
We have been working in Pakistan,
since we started Malala Fund.
Our first project started from Pakistan,
and that was to announce this
project which was the Education of 40
girls who were in domestic child labor.
So to give them education and
they're still learning,
they're still continuing their education.
They are in like higher grades now.
And since then, we have now done even,
more and bigger projects since then.
We have started a school in
the hometown of my parents Changla.
And Changla is considered to be one of
the most deprived and areas in Pakistan.
It's a mountainous area, and
this is the first school for
girls there where girls can
complete their secondary education.
And like every year we get hundreds and
1000s of applications.
And we can only pick a few students but
what you realize is that when quality
education is available, when the state
of the art school is available and
when parents feel safe for
their children to go to school.
Then the social norms and,
all that like stigma has been
associated with education for
girls changes really quickly,
and we see so many families
sending their daughters to school.
And so the positive chain
has already been seen, and
along with that we do our advocacy
through to the champions project.
And in Pakistan we have
many many champions and
activists there who we
are supporting in their world for
girls secondary education What do you
miss most about living in Pakistan?
>> I miss my home,
I miss I miss Swat Valley and Shangri-La,
those are very beautiful places.
And I miss my time with my friends.
Yeah, and the food as well of course,
you know.
I live in the UK so
[LAUGH] I always miss the food.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Got it.
So just before we move on to
the audience questions, the mission and
the vision Malala,
that you've taken on, is vast.
It's 130 million girls.
We hope it happens as fast as
possible albeit to multiple years and
it's fairly long term vision.
How do you stay motivated
on a day to day basis,
because in a business sense
you can win a deal and
kind of see very tangible
success on a regular basis.
This is more long term.
How do you stay motivated
on a daily basis?
>> I think that inaction
has worse consequences,
things remain as they are, so
keeping your work going is important.
So staying active is important for me,
and I believe that the work that we have
done and the work that, people in
the past have done for women's rights and
girls education in the in the work
that all organizations and
everyone is doing has brought us to
the stage and has helped us see progress.
So this work needs to continue and
we need to accelerate it and
we need to make it better and
we will see progress.
What's worse and what's, what I think
is dangerous is us all giving up rights.
We should not give up,
we should not stop this work.
So we have to carry on.
>> Inaction as complicity, yes.
The theme for our View from the Top
Speaker Series is beyond expectations,
and we like to ask all our speakers,
Malala,
what motivates you as a 24-year-old
girl from Swat, Pakistan,
to grow beyond the expectations
of a girl from Pakistan?
>> I am very ambitious and
I was like that in my childhood as well,
and I would always question society and
the world and
why it could not be better than it is.
Why do we see equality,
inequality with our own eyes and
don't do anything about it?
Why do we see that so
many people live in extreme poverties?
Why can't we change that?
Why is it that millions of
girls are out of school and
nobody does anything about that?
So I end, but then on the other hand,
I also remain ambitious,
that we can change that,
we can see that change in our own life.
And so this is something that I have
taken with me from my childhood,
is that you have to remain ambitious.
And, you have to be a bit more optimistic,
so
I remain optimistic and
ambitious in my goals to see all
girls in school in my lifetime,
>> Inshallah.
>> Great,
let's open it up to audience questions.
I believe we have one.
>> Hi Mahala, my name is Talia Han and
I'm an MBA one here.
As a fellow Pakistani woman it is
incredibly inspiring to see you here.
Thank you so much for coming here.
My question is as someone who has
personally navigated the challenges
of a patriarchal society,
I know there are millions of girls and
women back home who personally
faced restrictions,
whether it's access to education, whether
it's professional opportunities, or
even simply to have an independent
opinion of themselves.
On a more personal basis, what is your
advice to them in terms of keeping hope
alive for a more freer future?
What was the thing for you that
allowed you to continue staying so
resilient in your difficult times?
>> Thank you for that question.
So I'll share one story.
When I started speaking out in my
activism, I was only ten years old,
but then as I was growing older and
I was at age 13 and 14, and
especially in our society in the north
of Pakistan, it could become a taboo for
a girl to be on a TV screen and
speak out to media publicly,
not cover her face, and
some families may completely oppose that.
And I remember like one time, my dad
asked my cousin to take me to this press
conference area and my cousin just
felt extremely uncomfortable,
and then he told my dad that
Malala should not speak and
my dad told him that this
was none of his business.
He should not be deciding anything for
his daughter, and
that everything that Malala
does should be her own choice.
So, but today, that same cousin is
the biggest supporter of my cause,
and he's actually involved in in the work,
and he is so
passionate about girls education,
and he supports me in my work.
So initially,
you would see this unease among people.
You might even hear hateful comments,
or you might hear people feeling
just very uncomfortable to see
women in different roles and
in different positions, and
women having a loud voice, and
women being at the table, but
with time they'll get used to it.
And in a few years like before we know it,
things have already changed and
things already become like customs and
new norms.
So it's important for
us to remain ambitious and committed, and
it's, consistency is really important,
so we have to stick to it and
ensure that we carry this work on and
hopefully things will change.
We're already seeing so
much progress in Pakistan,
we have women in the parliament and
we have women in different jobs and
in different sectors and hopefully
it will get better, it will improve.
And a lot of women are speaking out
about women's safety at work and
in other spaces, and
speaking out against harassment, and
sexual harassment, so
there is this campaign going on for
Women's Equality in Pakistan and
that gives us hope.
>> Next question.
Here.
>> Hi Malala, I'm Bruno,
an MBA one here from Stanford GSB.
So first of all, I would like to
thank you for sharing your thoughts,
your brave story.
Definitely motivate us to make
the world a better place.
Well, I'm from developing country in Latin
America where education is not a right,
is a privilege, and I feel very
privileged to be here at Stanford.
As I know many boys and girls,
they didn't have an opportunity to
go to a proper elementary school.
You might heard my country,
that is Brazil.
So I'd like to ask you,
what are your thoughts about our
role as students from top
universities like Stanford, Oxford,
to minimize the gap between basic
education across the countries?
>> Thank you for that question.
I think you are all the future of
this world, you're all the future of
your countries and I would say that
remain ambitious about your goals and
you can bring change in your countries,
you can bring change in your communities.
And you already might
be a role model to so
many young kids who may not
have thought about themselves.
Completing their school going to
university and taking a role in society.
So, you are already giving hope to so
many people, so many women, especially
here who could be coming from developing
countries or from difficult backgrounds.
They're giving hope to so
many women and girls and
when a child sees somebody else
in their dress, in their outfit.
And when they see somebody
who looks like them,
they can imagine themselves
in that person's role.
So, you are already giving hope to so
many.
>> You've got a question?
>> Yeah, hi, Malala.
So my name is [INAUDIBLE],
I'm an MBA two, and
you may not remember this, but
we met a long, long time ago.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Do you remember?
>> So, in all fairness reason,
the reason she won't remember is because
she'd suffered a very bad infection and
she was in ICU after having
just been shot in the head.
The reason I remember is because
I was your doctor at the time and
I've followed your journey ever since the
difficulties you've had integrating new
cultures followed you through your
new school and Edgbaston High.
I tried to be part of a lot of fun
when I was at McKinsey as well.
I thought was a natural fit, but I come
from a family of strong feminists and
I've benefited from that as well.
But I have seen a massive conflict in
tradition versus progression and culture.
And I know we've asked a similar question,
but now that you've lived,
you've had the Pakistan experience,
you've had the westernized experience.
What do you think you can take
from the experiences you've had in
the western world?
And how do we take them back to
areas where they could benefit?
>> Thank you for that question, and
you thank you for all your support, and
nice to see you again.
>> [LAUGH]
>> When I started living in the UK there
were so many things that surprised us we
were living in cold weather forever and
we were missing our nice warm summer
days in Pakistan but other than that,
I started studying in a school where
we were getting quality education.
That was the first time when I realized
that education is not just about sciences
and maths and learning English, but
students also learn cooking and sports and
textiles and these are not the subjects
that you often see in schools in Pakistan.
And it really challenges you to
think about education in different
ways in which the goal is not to make
somebody a doctor or engineer only.
But to ensure that anyone
can go to that institution,
they can explore their their abilities and
they can explore their specialties,
and then realize and
reach their full potential.
So, when I was studying in
the UK I realized that education
is not just limited to sciences and
maths and those subjects.
But then also along with that there's a
good health system and you are much safer.
But your home is your home and
you miss so many things about your home.
When you are with your friends and
family and
you are sitting in your sort of dining
room with your family friends and
you are enjoying nice food and
you are surrounded by
this beautiful valley in
these lush green hills.
You're happy and
you're still having like a joyful time.
So, I think for
us even though we were having
all those facilities we would
still miss Pakistan all the time.
And I have seen this in many
places people consider the west
to be sort of the standard of
prosperity and development and
I think we need to sort
of challenge that a bit.
Because the pandemic and the recent events
have exposed how the systems in many
countries are not the ideal systems.
They are still not favoring the most
marginalized people in society,
they are discriminating against people
based on their income background,
based on their skin color,
based on their gender.
So, we need to be a bit more critical
of the system that we idolize and
it's possible for Pakistan and
other countries to improve their systems.
And this is a challenge for countries all
over the world to improve their systems,
to ensure that they provide welfare
to all its citizens and it's based on
adjust an equal system, so nobody is
left out and nobody is treated unfairly.
>> Great, thank you for those questions.
Before we add Malala,
we left to another lightning round.
So, I'll share a phrase and
just give me your quick thoughts on those.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Ready?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, okay, perfect.
This one should be easy.
>> Okay.
>> Or squid games.
>> So, is that Apple TV over Netflix or
I mean.
>> I'm partnering with Apple to be.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The right answer.
>> Yeah, by the way,
I started a production company
extracurricular just for the context.
And we're partnering with Apple TV plus,
so, yeah, it has to be a dead last.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Favorite queer eye actor.
>> I don't have any names,
I'm so bad at names.
>> Okay.
>> You can suggest and I can pick one.
>> Jonathan Van Ness but no.
>> No, I'm bad at this.
>> No worries.
>> The only name I usually like
when you talk about actors and
actresses I know all the Bollywood ones.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then I know Brad Pitt and
>> Leonardo DiCaprio and
that said [LAUGH].
>> How about this one or world Federer
who you have not met but want to.
>> A world Federer.
So, it's not a politician.
It's not a politician, but
I really want to meet Vanessa Nekate,
she's a climate activist and
I have been following her journey and
I would want to see her in person.
>> Right.
Favorite social media platform.
>> I mean, it has to be Instagram.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Ignore, I think it's Twitter,
it's hard to pick but
it's between those two.
Sometimes it's Twitter I mean,
when anything happens you want to go
to Twitter right just just see tweets
on it and then Instagram is also good.
But yeah, whenever I'm following cricket,
I just go straight to Twitter and
just see what people have have said.
It's very funny.
>> Same yeah.
Where do you store your Nobel Peace Prize?
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's confidential, you'll never know.
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, great.
And then last one favorite Adele song.
I'll Say hello.
>> Awesome.
Well, this has been a lot of fun for
me personally and for you as well and
we appreciate your time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you so much.
Thank you.
>> Absolutely, and.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
Thank you, so nice to see you.
Thank you.
[MUSIC]